PROFESSOR: We're going to spend
a couple of minutes talking
about the binomial
theorem, which is probably
familiar to you
from high school,
and is a nice first
illustration of the connection
between algebra and computation.
So the idea that
underlies the connection
is illustrated by
the distributive law.
And I'm purposely writing
it in this wacky way--
it's purely symbolic--
where I'm going to multiply
three beanies by two neckties.
What do I get if I multiply
three beanies by two neckties?
Well, applying the
distributive law
says that we get every
possible pairing of a beanie
and a necktie
multiplied together
and you add them all up.
So there are three terms
here and two terms there.
I'm going to wind up with six
terms, which you see laid out.
The basic rule is that a product
of sums by the distributive law
becomes a sum of products.
And the sums that
you get involves
products of all of the terms
from each of the components
in every possible way.
Let's look at that as it
applies to the binomial theorem.
So the binomial theorem is
interested in the question
of let's look at
the expression 1
plus x raised to the NTH power.
And we know that this will
be a polynomial of degree n,
so it can be written in the form
a constant, c0 plus c1 times
x to 1, c2 x to the
2, cn x to the n.
And we like to ask, what
are the expressions for ck?
So for example, here's a layout
of the first four powers of x.
Let's say 1 plus x to the fourth
is 1 plus 4x plus 6x squared
4x cubed 1x fourth.
What's the pattern that
underlies those coefficients,
1, 4, 6, 4, 1?
Well, one way to
think about it is
that if I wrote out
1 plus x to the n
fully it is, of course, a
product of n occurrences of 1
plus x times 1 plus x.
And applying the distributive
law, the product of sums
equals sum of products rule, but
this time there are n products.
And what I wind up with is 2 to
the n terms that I'm adding up.
Each of them is a product of
a selection of n items, one
from each of the factors.
So a term among these
2 to the n terms
corresponds to
selecting a 1 or an x
from each of the n factors.
So if I started off, for
example, by selecting a 1,
a 1, a 1 from each
of the n factors,
I'd get the term 1 to the n.
If I selected an x, an x, an
x, an x from each of the terms,
I'd get this last
term x to the n.
And if I made some arbitrary
selection, like I selected
an x from the first one, and a
1 from the second one, and a 1
from the third one-- I'm reading
this term-- 1 from the fourth,
and so on, and x from the
next to the last, and a 1
from the last, I would get this
particular term, which is not
the next one that would
occur in alphabetical order,
but it's just an example.
So that's the simple idea.
If you multiply out n
terms, each of which
is a sum of two
things, you're going
to wind up with 2 to the
n terms corresponding
to every possible
way of selecting
one or the other
of the components
from each of the n products.
So what's the coefficient
of x to the k?
Well, the coefficient
of x to the k
is the number of those
terms among the 2
to the n in which
the power of x is k.
That is, in which I selected
k x's and willy nilly
n minus k ones.
Well, how many ways
are there to select
k x's among these n terms?
And we know the answer to that.
It's n choose k.
It's all the ways of
choosing a subset of k items
out of n items.
And that's the answer.
ck is simply n choose k.
And this is called
the binomial formula.
So now we know that
1 plus x to the n
is n choose 0 plus n choose
1x, n choose 2x squared.
n choose kx to the k
is the general term.
Ending with n choose
n to the x to the n.
So this expression, 1 plus x,
is called a binomial expression.
And the choose numbers,
which we've seen previously,
is the number of ways
to choose, in this case,
k out of n elements, are
called binomial coefficients.
And this is why they're
So if I was going to
express it more generally,
I didn't need it to be 1.
I used 1 plus x just
because it was easier
to follow the structure
of the formula.
But if I look at x plus
y to the NTH power,
again, the coefficients
are the same.
It's n choose 0, but this
time y to the n, n choose 1,
xy to the n minus 1.
What's happening now is that
I'm choosing an x or a y
instead of an x or a 1
from each of the terms,
so that the xy terms are always
going to have a sum of degrees
that is equal to n.
If I choose k x's, I must
have chosen n minus k y's.
And there it is
expressed in more concise
form using sigma notation.
That is the binomial formula.